les écoutes elles ont déjà des envies
d'interagir avec vous donc j'ai demandé
de me poser des questions sur twitter
auxquelles je répondrai voilà et ce sont
des conseils que je vais vous donner
pour mener une vie sereine parfaite
vraiment où tout va bien que faire quand
on a mal partout après deux heures de
musculation et qu'on doit aller faire
des courses à pied aux mains tout petit
os yonne c'est une relève vim
on sait qu'on part nadeau maire du mat
et eup la mort d'anna faire plaisir
maintenant tu bois ça boit ça où tu te
faire céder plus capable de faire ta
position foetale
alors on y va c'est extrêmement simple
ça conseille vraiment utile dans la vie
tous les jours tu fais la position de
terrain de sécurité voilà c'est juste un
peu plus cher que faire quand on n'a pas
de poils et battu profite de la vie
[ __ ] tu la quittes encore plus tu
transpires - des aisselles et attire
plus les offres y a tout pour être
heureux [ __ ] par exemple voilà d'où ma
vie je vais être très malheureux la
partie de la famille qui va des cv et
d'une touche du bois tout du pit en
bourse
ce gros court que faire si à force de
dire on s'en bat les steaks les steaks
nous déclare la guerre et forme des
complots nazis battu les pur-sang
ballester que tu dis on s'en bat les
poissons voilà comme ça plus embrouillé
o o o one elle nous demande que faire si
je veux me muscler écoute j'adorerais
vraiment pouvoir du conseiller te donner
des tips est tous un peu cool les
mouvements à faire et tout ça parce que
je pensais sont toujours absents que
faire c'est l'ascenseur reste bloqué que
je suis avec un fille alors je sais pas
trop ce que tu insinues mais si tu avec
un fille fait quand même attention tu
bras avoir des [ __ ] de surprise que
faire si le tueur donne-t-il d'un déchet
toile la dragée haute aux parce que le
tueur d'huntingdon il permet de 20
que faire si on a deux soeurs
insupportable on les vend tu les veux
elles sont propres et cuisine bien g
idée de quoi en faire et 0 xp tous mes
persos sur démarrer cette chaise c'est
intéressant que faire si on te kiffe
trop hausser chouba c'est très simple tu
t'emballes un [ __ ] jane youtube du lac
tout même vidéo tu commandes je t'aime
tu es beau château on leur fixe des
foules sur twitter facebook et à gramat
google+ aussi à cet important n'oubliez
pas et tu parles pas de doute les
[ __ ] d'avis à tautavel je t'aime que
faire si je me fais bouffer sur un
guerrier alors que j'étais premier de la
partie pendant un moment
éric lefebvre de demande conseil que
faire si ma copine me plaque mon gars tu
arrives tu la plaque au style direct
beaux arts dont la chaîne là pour la
troisième fois aux ados les attendait
mais ça c'est les jambes de ta maman ça
comme ça hein
et après allez monsieur y arriver comme
ça c'est super ça désolé c'est vraiment
horrible
voilà vous êtes mal à l'aise bah moi
aussi je le suis voilà on a tous mal s
écoule n'en règle au faible c'était
copine te plaques et coûteux passer à
autre chose tombe à l'estec là que faire
si on est ingérable aussi moche que
celle que tu as dessinée je suis dit tu
prend cher à chaque vidéo genre les gens
tour et des braves ont étouffé les
delattre et il aurait mis les tee-shirts
ou tv dessus tu devrais dire quelque
chose bordel et là je comprends pourquoi
est-elle que je comprends tes la turne
mur tu crois je vous lis agréable je
plaque
que faire si ta gueule que faire si j'ai
deux pénis on peut s'arranger avec les
deux soeurs qu'on vient de me donner
effectivement oui que faire si on n'a
pas d'amis bat margaux tu je parle pour
toi pas pour moi mais j'aime et j'ai des
amis des bonjour les gars j'ai des amis
que faire si on a faim
non mais c'est tout bon mec
vas-y vas-y voilà c'est que faire si le
lave-vaisselle explose bah du coup tu
dois racheter de la vaisselle qui donc
sera propre donc objectif atteint et
ouais mon gars que faire si boulette
rigole s'te plaît rigole s'te plaît
rigole s'te plaît pas pour pauline et
fait pas semblant oui mon allégeance
d'hier prendre cette vidéo j'espère que
ce genre de vidéos vous plaît c'est vrai
qu'on veut c'est d'un étonnant n'a pas
fait beaucoup
donc ça vous plaît ne s'est pas aimé la
vidéo et puis j'essaierai d'en faire
plus souvent trouvé des petites idées
comme ça bon c'est pas pour folichon
mais bon merci à tous d'avoir participé
c'était super cool ils purent se trouve
très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
peut-être spéciale qui sait ouais
allez je vous dis à bientôt je vois ça
trop c est dallas pris cher pis
[Musique]